ralph waldo emerson a écrit les gens ne
semble pas se rendre compte que leur
opinion sur le monde révèle la
personnalité et moi je trouve cette
phrase vraiment trop cool parce que dans
les gens il faut comprendre 100 % des
gens pas seulement les imbéciles et
quand on regarde cette idée en tête et
qu'on observe le comportement des autres
est le sien après vers elle comme à
travers un filtre révélateur c'est assez
étonnant
par exemple monsieur x sort du cinéma
outré et déclare que tel film est un
navet si on écoute attentivement on se
rend compte que la réaction de monsieur
x est en fait bourré d'informations sur
lui dire qu'un film est raté
c'est en fait dire que le film ne
correspond pas à ses désirs à ce qu'ils
auraient aimé voir parce qu'il aurait
voulu que le film soit c'est à dire que
ça révèle ses envies ses préférences ses
valeurs et si monsieur x prétend
proposer un jugement sur la valeur
objectif du film cette ambition est elle
aussi révélatrice pensait qu'il existe
des oeuvres objectivement raté c'est à
voir certaines croyances relatives à la
réalité
et puis il ya plein de manières
différentes d'expérimenter un film qui
ne correspond pas à ce qu'on aurait
voulu voir
il y ajoute un spectre un tiens j'aurais
préféré voir autre chose tant pis j'ai
perdu deux heures ma vie c'est un peu
con l'intensité de la réaction le
mélange des sentiments la déception
l'agacement la colère le cynisme le
mépris tout cela révèle la manière dont
on aborde une expérience et la manière
dont on aborde une expérience ça en dit
beaucoup sur notre personnalité
voilà à nouveau la célébration
spinoziste on ne désire pas une chose
parce qu'elle est bonne on juge bonnes
les choses que l'on désire combien de
nos raisonnements sont en réalité des
justification a posteriori de préférence
tout à fait arbitraire et parfois même
inconsciente
combien de nos convictions qui nous
paraissent pourtant solidement
construite ne sont en fait que
l'expression sophistiqué de nos désirs
c'est frappant quand il ya des
incompréhensions entre des philosophes
ou sur twitter entre des personnes qui
se revendiquent de l'esprit critique ou
carrément de la méthode scientifique
je ne parle pas de désaccord mais bien
d'incompréhension contre pas tous
d'accord qu'on partage pas tous les
mêmes valeurs à la limite il n'y a rien
de très surprenant là dedans mais il est
mal entendu les incompréhensions c'est
le symptôme d'autres choses
plus on est préoccupé par la validité de
nos raisonnements et la fiabilité de nos
croyances et plus en risque de penser
que l'opinion que l'on se fait sur tel
ou tel sujet est une construction aussi
solide que neutre comme si on avait
réussi à produire un regard pur de tout
désir inconscient dans la plupart des
incompréhensions
on dirait que chaque partie se comporte
comme si leur position était bâtie sur
de purs idées et des concepts
parfaitement transparente d'où
l'étonnement
mais comment se fait-il qu'ils ne me
comprends pas je suis pourtant super car
c'est un peu naïf d'imaginer que nous
pourrions nous soustraire à tout
investissement émotionnel
alors même qu'on parle de choses qui
nous intéresse non il ya toujours tapi
derrière nos pensées des désirs des
craintes des attentes des angoisses
peut-être qu'on peut tenir tous à aller
car quand on résout une équation
mais dès qu'on s'exprime sur la société
sur les comportements des uns et des
autres sur les relations entre individus
il me semble évident que notre regard
est profondément coloré par nos désirs
et ce d'une manière très souvent
imperceptibles pour nos propres yeux
quand quelque chose nous énerve nous
bouscule nous fascine nous séduit on
devrait prendre le temps de creuser ce
qui motive cette réaction
ce serait se donner l'occasion d'en
apprendre davantage sur soi même et
aussi de développer un peu plus de
tolérance vis-à-vis des autres c'est un
peu comme la parabole du chien et la
voiture développée ici n'oublions pas
que l'on vous débattre tous avec nos
angoisses